MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
everyone.
Thank you for making your way up
into the inner recesses of
the Googleplex here.
We're very pleased to host a
true inventor in our midst
today for Talks at Google.
We actually have Brett
Stern here.
He's an industrial designer and
inventor, currently living
in Portland, Oregon.
So he has the whole Portlandia
thing going on.
His contributions span a
variety of industries--
anything from the textile and
pharmaceutical industries to
consumer packaged goods.
Things like Beer Chips, which
are actually quite amazing.
He speaks to us today about
his new book, which is
entitled "Inventors at Work." In
it, he profiles a series of
inventors across industries,
looks for commonalities, does
some in person and phone
interviews, and creates this
book that is now part of the "At
Work" series, continuing
the tradition of coders
at work and so forth.
He describes common threads and
Eureka moments from people
like Steve Wozniak and the
inventor of the Leatherman,
which are both very near and
dear to the tech work that we
do here at Google.
So without further ado, please
join me in welcoming Brett to
the Googleplex.
[APPLAUSE]
BRETT STERN: So, I am an
industrial designer, and most
people have no idea
what that is.
They go to the store, they buy
stuff, and they don't really
think what's behind it.
When I try to explain what an
industrial designer is,
there's this very vague look
on people's faces.
And then I say, well,
you know an iPhone
is designed so great?
And they're like, yeah,
we understand that!
And then they say, well, did
you design the iPhone?
And then I have to say no, and
they're sort of upset.
And so I've learned over years
and come to accept that I tell
people now that I'm
an inventor.
And everyone knows
one inventor.
They sort of have these romantic
thoughts in their
head of a lone guy
in a garage--
maybe crazy, or maybe he's a
genius, they don't really
know-- but sort of working the
late night oil, and just sort
of making something new to make
the world a better place,
make our lives easier,
and so forth.
So I do have that background.
I am an industrial designer,
though I like to sort of step
back and work on projects before
you even know what the
problem is.
And that's sort of how I work
the inventor side in.
So this project came along,
the "Inventors at Work,"
Apress the publisher.
They've done a number of
books in this series.
And so they just said, hey,
go figure the book out.
Work within the format we're
doing, which is go out and
find people within that
industry, interview them,
whatever questions you want,
and then sort of edit these
conversations to do
whatever you want.
I read a great deal about
inventors, about creative
people, and the process
and so forth.
I feel I'm able to go from
surgical instruments to potato
chips easily, because I
understand the process of what
it is to be a creative person
and how to think
broadly over that.
And so my goal of this project
was not to talk to these
inventors about their products,
which generally most
stories talk about, but
rather the process.
So it wasn't about the product
they were doing, but about the
process that they go
through every day.
And the goal was, what I was
trying to learn and what I'm
trying to convey to the reader,
is what are those--
are there commonalities?
Are there certain traits that
we inventive people, we
creative people have inside of
us that somehow makes us
different from all the other
kids on the block?
And so, going into it, I would
sort of start this generic
question, and try to dial down
and try to seek what they were
really thinking,
how they think.
And it's not so much thinking
when they're behind their
keyboard or their desk or their
drawing board, but how
they're thinking during the day,
at night, when they're
sleeping, when they're
on top of a mountain.
Just how they think, and what
their process is to go from
point A to point B. And so my
presentation is going to be
what I learned from doing this
book, and what these
commonalities are,
and so forth.
Now, when I started the book,
I had carte blanche to just
find any inventor that I wanted,
and that's sort of
like the dream list.
And the reality is, when you say
inventors, you know their
inventions, but you
don't really know
the person, the inventor.
I mean, we know Thomas Edison.
We may know Steve Wozniak and a
few other technical people.
But we really don't know
the person behind it.
So my process was to just start
with this empty slate,
and put down industries or
technologies or products that
I wanted to know.
Obvious electronics--
computers and things
like that.
Transportation, medical,
communication, fun, sports,
materials, whatever it was.
And then my process was to go
out there and find these
people and do the process.
And the process was just sort
of going online and frankly,
Googling the companies or the
people that I wanted to do,
and then just continuously
research who these people
were, finding everything out
there was about them.
And then I would be interviewing
them, mostly on
the phone, through Skype,
through videoconferencing,
putting all these conversations
into
conversations, having them
transcribed, then editing them
out, creating Word documents,
sitting in an Ergon chair with
my noise cancelling
headsets on.
And while I was doing this,
I just realized all the
technology and all the
inventions that allowed me to
sit in a chair in my room all
by myself to sort of find
these people out there
was just amazing.
So the presentation will talk
about these commonalities.
So dreaming.
"When I was young, I would go
to sleep thinking about
computer programs or computer
hardware problems or math
problems in school.
Sleep and think, and think as
I fell asleep, working the
variables in my head, seeing
the lines of code.
And then I would wake up in
the middle of the night
sometimes and have a solution
that would save one line of
code in a program.
So I believe very much that
your mind is working while
you're dreaming."
Steve Wozniak.
I mean, we all know
who this guy was.
And of all these common traits,
I think the biggest
one that makes us unique
as creative
people is this dreaming.
And somehow, dreaming has a
negative connotation in
today's society--
like, you're daydreaming, you're
wandering off, you're
not focused, just pay
attention here.
That you can't pay attention.
But dreaming is just
sort of essential.
I mean, it's somewhat of a
childlike thing, because we do
it all as a child.
And hopefully as an
adult, we can
continue that in the process.
So this daydreaming, or this
dreaming, is really a very
important quality.
And this is, I think, out of
all these traits is the one
thing that you cannot be taught
or educated or advance.
It's either in you and
you allow it to
happen or you don't.
And I think that's what makes us
as creative inventive types
different from the rest of
the people out there.
So pondering.
"I know that if I go to a
seminar or a conference to
hear someone talk, I'll drift
off, because the mechanism, or
the chemistry, or the approach
that they're talking about
spurs an idea that might
be useful in solving or
addressing some of the
problems I have.
Even when it's not really what
the guy or lady is talking
about specifically, but
something analogous to that."
So the pondering.
This is Al Maurice.
He's a polymer chemist at Dow
Chemical, and what he
developed was the polymers to
go from oil based paints to
acrylic based paints.
Now, if you're at a certain
age, there was always oil
based paints.
And if you went down to the
garage, there was a coffee can
with a stiff brush in there all
sort of stuck together.
And if you walked into a room
that was just painted with oil
based paints, you would smell
the fumes, and you'd get a
headache or you'd drift
off or something.
Well, this guy figured out all
the polymer chemistry.
So he wasn't developing paint,
but it was the thing to go
into the thing to the thing.
And so it was just so far
removed, but his days were
just mixing chemicals together
to get to this final point.
And so he'd been working,
literally, on the same problem
for the last 30 years to make
water-based paints.
And the fun part of asking
these people just general
questions is I actually got
to ask him the process.
And he'd go, well, we mix all
these things together, and we
basically put the paint
out there, and then
we'd watch it dry.
And I was like, you actually got
paid to watch paint dry.
And so he really did get paid
to watch paint dry.
Just fascinating.
It just really used the process
of creativity to
develop all these things.
Also, some of these people were
corporate people, some
were academia, some
governmental,
some guys in a garage.
Al works at Dow Chemical,
certainly a well known company
that promotes technology and
promotes innovation.
What was interesting, that there
are companies out there,
and I'm sure Google is very
similar, that once you become
successful in what you're
doing, you go up
the corporate ladder.
But companies like Dow,
companies like Corning,
companies like IBM and GE, they
allow their technical
people to advance and go up
the corporate ladder, but
still stay, in a sense, in the
lab doing their research.
So they didn't have to
become a manager.
If they wanted to,
they could do it.
And I think Al, at some point,
had become a manager.
But really, he was managing
the innovation, the
creativity.
But he is still in
the lab every day
mixing things together.
"To prospective inventors, I say
rule one is perseverance.
If you're working on an
invention, at some point,
you're probably going to think
about giving up and going on
to something else.
I realize there's a fine line
between perseverance and
failure to accept reality.
But I recommend that you lean
toward staying with it too
long rather than giving up too
soon." That's Tim Leatherman,
who happens to be in Portland,
Oregon, who I
interviewed in person.
And so I'm sure everyone knows
the Leatherman tool.
There actually is a guy named
Tim Leatherman behind
Leatherman Tools.
And they actually have developed
leather working
tools, but no one
ever buys them.
So he was trained as a
mechanical engineer, travelled
around in the early '70s in
Europe with his soon to be
wife, bought a car, stayed
in cheap hotels.
And he was always fixing this
car or fixing the plumbing in
these cheap hotels traveling
around Europe.
And so he was always looking for
pliers or screwdrivers or
tools to sort of fix
his daily routine.
And so when he came back, even
though he was trained as an
engineer and actually worked
when he got out of school in
engineering, he decided he
wanted to develop this
multi-purpose tool that has
now become part of the
vernacular, and actually spent
seven years in his garage,
from the time of making his
first prototype to then
actually commercialization.
So here's a man, for seven
years, just living--
he was not working, just going
broke trying to develop the
Leatherman tool.
And now his proudest achievement
is actually not
the tool, but they do all their
manufacturing in Portland.
So he has 300 people there in
Portland and making the thing.
And so he feels the greatest
thing that he's done is
actually employing 300 people
to produce his product.
"Failure is a way of learning.
What may be considered failures
are actually other
great ideas." Anybody
know Robert Denard?
He invented RAM memory.
I mean, memory.
It's what we all live
on right now.
He's 84-years-old.
He's a senior fellow
at IBM, still in
there every day working.
Pretty amazing.
Now, when you invent something,
there's always this
prior art--
what someone did beforehand.
And what was fascinating talking
to Bob was what he
did, there really was nothing
before there.
Everything was a bunch
of tubes and
vacuums and so forth.
So he really is the first one
who created something new,
which is just such a
rarity these days.
And I think one of things we
get hung up as people, as a
society, is failure
is a bad thing.
But failure is such
a great thing.
You learn what's not working for
that particular problem,
but you have that experience,
and you go on and apply that
knowledge to something else
at a future point.
Self motivation.
"You know, when there's a
certain joy to what you do,
and when you have this certain
energy, that's
what makes me happy.
Doing these things
made me happy.
That was the real motivation.
It made me happy." So Gary
Mickelson is a spinal surgeon.
And just to give you an idea how
successful he was, he sold
all his patents-- about 250--
in 2005 for $1.4 billion.
Totally changed the way
everything did.
What was interesting, here
is a man who is totally
successful in what he's doing,
but totally insecure about was
he ever really successful
in doing this?
And he said, every time he would
create something, and
when he was a resident, all the
doctors would say, don't
do that, you're wrong,
you're stupid.
Do it my way that I've always
done it before.
And the biggest thing he said
that the doctors told him, the
biggest reservation they had is,
like, don't kill anybody.
And so when we invent something,
we think, oh, well,
that program won't work, or that
toy won't work, whatever.
Well, he could paralyze
people or kill people.
So it's just fascinating that
he really changed the whole
subject matter and the whole
range of medical procedures.
Seek inspiration outside your
field. "Solutions kind of
flash into your brain
at some point.
I can't really explain what my
subconscious activity is,
especially these days.
I like to spend a lot of my time
on my farm pushing rocks
around with my tractor.
It's a background process or
subconscious process I really
cannot explain.
Usually it's related to having
a problem I want to solve.
I don't sit back and dream up
solutions to things that don't
have a problem yet, but when
faced with a problem, usually
the solutions, in my field, at
least, come pretty quickly.
I can't give you a recipe
for invention.
That's impossible."
So Eric was a physicist.
He was a professor at Columbia
doing research.
And then in the early '80s,
got brought out to Jet
Propulsion Labs to work on
satellite camera systems.
At the time, they were
all film based, and
used big heavy batteries.
And they were shooting two,
three satellites up, and they
needed to record everything.
What he developed was
a digital camera.
Every digital camera on
your phone now is
stuff that he developed.
So he did this back
in the '80s.
When we talk to him in this day
and age, I said, did you
ever think 30 years later, 20
years later, that every phone
would have a camera?
And he's still redeveloping this
technology today, and now
they're on cameras.
But he's saying, eventually,
you're going to be swallowing
these cameras and looking
inside of you and taking
pictures, which their
researchers are doing already.
So it's just fascinating.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious,
was the camera-- did it come
from an inspiration outside
of what he was working on?
BRETT STERN: You know, I don't
really know where he found
that inspiration from.
It's a good question.
But I think what he was sort of
saying there-- that because
he was a physicist, he didn't
approach this as a camera
solution or as a
film solution.
He was just looking outside
of the typical field.
And I think a lot of the people
that I interviewed
found solutions in
other venues.
Sharing ideas with others.
"Motivating a group to be
creative is not difficult.
I believe that sharing ideas
is the secret to developing
new concepts.
If you can create an atmosphere
of honestly sharing
whatever comes to your mind, I
don't care how brilliant you
are, or how slow thinking
anybody is.
If they're willing to open up
and let whatever they say or
think come to the floor and
share with everyone else, even
if it's the stupidest idea,
and they know it's stupid,
when they say it, it often
leads to something.
When you get two, three, or
four people together in a
room, and you just open up and
say whatever you're thinking,
good things will happen."
So Reyn Guyer, the Nerf ball.
I mean, it's the Nerf ball.
I mean, this is the other
extreme of what
invention is all about.
And what the guy invented before
the Nerf ball, because
it was all about playing?
He invented the Twister game.
And I think that's actually
even a more
amazing thing, because--
and this is pretty dated, but
back in the mid '60s when he
developed this, society was
much more restrained and
conservative.
But basically, Twister opened up
where people could actually
touch each other and physically
interact with each
other, really changing the
social dynamics of society in
something what he was doing.
So able to visualize ideas in
their heads. "I visualize in
three dimensions what the
products look like, and being
such a hands-on builder of
products, I like to very
quickly get into the three
dimensional form.
I spend half an hour on a simple
sketch, then get right
into trying to build something,
either carving out
of foam with a rasp, or building
Bondo onto a last
shape."
Martin Keen with
Keen Footwear.
Anybody know Keen Footwear?
So, totally changed how shoes
look, but really changed how
shoes feel.
So he's an industrial
designer also.
So very hands-on type
of guy, as I am.
So before, the way shoes were
designed where the factory
would have the last, which
is the shoe shape.
They would give it to the
designer, this generic shape
of all different sizes.
And they would just sort of
design around the shoe last.
What he did, he actually went
out and cast people's feet.
Now, it sounds so obvious to
do something like that, but
the designers never really
had that option
before, to be that hands-on.
And because of that, if you've
ever worn Keen Footwear, they
really fit a lot better.
And they're really
comfortable.
And now, if you look at the way
shoes are, certainly the
toe shape, they really have
changed because of what he's
put in there.
A touch of obsession.
"I saw 'Star Wars' on the big
screen when I was 11.
It was 1977, and I fell
in love with R2-D2.
If you've seen 'Star Wars,'
you'll know that R2-D2 is more
than a machine.
He has a personality, he has
an agenda, and he is one of
the main characters.
It was the first time I
saw potentially what a
machine could be.
Now, we're not there yet, but
my motivation is R2-D2."
This is Helen Greiner.
The company she had at
the time was iRobot.
And consumer-wise, you may know
of the Roomba robot that
sort of goes around your
apartment to clean it up.
But really, what they've made
their money for, and really
the technology developed are
all the robots that are in
Iran and Iraq to disassemble
bombs out there.
Just an amazing thing
what they're doing.
And just a brilliant woman
from MIT, and just really
changed the way what machines
could think and how they could
see and they can move.
And this is just all what she's
thinking about all day.
"So the neat thing about 3M is
that we have experts in just
about every field that you
can possibly imagine.
We've all got these people
who are willing to help.
But you need to take
advantage. of
it." Matthew Scholz.
So he's a researcher at 3M.
Has anybody ever broken their
arm and had a cast?
All right, all those casts,
that's this guy.
If anybody has ever had an
operation, and they put this
film on your body for
anti-microbal, where it sort
of separates, that's this
guy over there.
Completely different things.
But what's important to him is
that he didn't necessarily
know all the ideas and all the
solutions, but he was able to
go out into his surrounding
force and ask a lot of
questions, the [INAUDIBLE]
experts.
And I'm sure each one of you
are experts with your own
thing, but sometimes you
don't really know.
And so the commonality here
was just continuously ask
questions to people.
Work in multidisciplinary teams.
"I only work with teams
of people with a variety of
different backgrounds--
engineers, scientists,
biologists, nutritional
scientists.
In order for an initiative to
be successfully impactful,
each person of a teams is
critical, and the one person
alone won't be able to do it.
The initial technical area or
original concept might be one
person's contribution, but it'll
need to be reduced to
practice in the lab, scaled
up, utility-tested and
vetted."
Bernard works right now
at General Mills.
I assume you all eat dried
cereal in the morning.
Well, all those little
marshmallow shapes, or all
those little round donuts and
everything, this is what this
guy developed.
So he was trained as a food
scientist, but when he got out
of school back in the late '60s,
there were all these new
extrusion machines that
were coming about.
And he actually got a job
working for this company to
promote this machine, in a
sense, sell the machine with
this food background.
So he went into the marketplace
and trained all
these people how to use this
extrusion machine.
So now all the dried cereals
and crackers and flatbreads
that you eat are because
of this guy over here.
Continuous learning. "I think
you try to look for colleagues
who you can learn stuff from,
and you always have to be
learning stuff from different
people." So Karen is a
scientist at the Naval
Research Labs.
I'm assuming you do people
know of DARPA?
Well, the Naval Research
Labs are similar that
they're doing work.
Her current project is she's
developed this fuel cell that
can have a drone fly for 24
hours just on hydrogen.
So you can imagine
the implications.
And it's not a big plane, but
it's still something that is
elevated for 24 hours.
The concept is that aircraft and
boats and eventually cars
could run on these fuel
cells out there.
Now, she is a chemist and a
brilliant woman, but she is
working with all these just PhD
people out there that she
can go and put these teams
together and continuously find
new solutions to problems.
Work on multiple projects. "Our
teams are working on many
separate projects
simultaneously.
It does create a din of
discussions that's sometimes
hard to separate.
But I do find that
working on them
simultaneously forces synergies.
Inventors and innovators usually
have very busy minds,
so to try to keep ourselves
focused on one
thing becomes a challenge.
We try to make sure we have
outlets for multiple tracks of
thought, whether they're
personal projects that we are
doing outside of work or
multiple internal projects
that we're working on.
This multitask approach keeps
the ideas flowing."
So these three gentlemen are
also industrial designers.
They're at Motorola Solutions.
And they're working on police
communications.
You know, where the police all
have their radios on their
side, or the FedEx guy,
the UPS guys?
And they were just fascinated,
because they really get out
there into the marketplace
and really see how
people think and work.
And their goal is really to
come up with solutions--
not their solutions, but
really going into the
marketplace and asking
the marketplace what
the solutions are.
Well, what was fascinating is
that these guys are working,
and a lot of these people I
talked to were working on 5,
10, 15 projects at a time.
And I think that's important.
I know personally it's because
you start a project and you're
all excited, and you have all
this energy, and you ramp up
these thoughts.
And then there's time lags.
You sort of have to put
projects on hold.
And I think the idea of working
on multiple projects
gives you that opportunity to
sort of go up and down in your
cycle in working on
these things.
Ask lots of questions. "To a
large degree, we want to have
a good understanding of what
the problem is that we're
trying to solve, because
scientists have great ideas,
and there's never a
shortage of that.
I think the key way that we
approach research, certainly
on our more applied programs, is
that we want to get aligned
with the right problem, So I
think it's fair to say that a
lot of the biggest challenges
in doing innovation is
tackling or asking the right
question, identifying the
right problem."
So Glen is at General
Electric.
They're developing these
hybrid batteries for
locomotives to eventually
run on batteries,
not diesel fuel anymore.
What was interesting about
Glenn is that he works at
General Electric.
And if you look at the inventing
process, and if you
look at the king of inventor,
that's Thomas Edison.
Just one thing he said to me,
when they walk into their
door, Thomas Edison's
desk is right there.
And just that heritage just
drove these people for
perfection, and just keep
pushing themselves, and to
really say what's out there.
Also, General Electric
was really probably
the first R&D lab.
So it went from being the lone
crazy guy in the garage to
setting up in a corporate
atmosphere--
in a sense, where
you are today.
Prototype quickly. "Yes, I'm
going to stick my finger into
a moving table saw blade.
Your whole life, you have been
told not to do that.
Your body is telling you,
no, don't do this.
This is stupid."
So I don't know if anybody's
heard of a saw stop table saw,
or ever seen a demonstration,
or has anybody done
woodworking before?
And so you know that blade is
spinning really fast, and your
fingers are getting
really close.
So he's developed a saw that,
when it comes into contact
with any part of the body, will
stop in 1/10,000 of a
second, and will not cut
your finger off.
What was interesting is that the
industry has, for years,
sort of acknowledging the
problem, but sort of putting a
guard on that they know everyone
will take off,
because it just gets
in the way.
But since no one had
solved the problem,
that was the solution.
Everyone said, just be careful,
wear your safety goggles.
His background was he actually
has a PhD in physics, but
didn't want to teach, so went
back to school to become a
patent attorney.
And then was doing woodworking
on the side, and then
realized, here's
a problem here.
And when he was explaining the
process to me, he didn't look
at this from a mechanical
standpoint at all.
He just looked at it.
He's a physicist, and he just
had these facts in his head
that because I'm a physicist,
I know this, this, and this,
and of course it should work.
And so we had this whole
discussion, and literally, in
a half hour, he said he
prototyped this thing.
And then I said, well, how did
you decide to test this?
And he goes, well, the first
one is we used a
hot dog, and it worked.
But then I'm obligated to stick
my finger into this
thing, which I can't really
imagine that, because I do
woodworking too.
The conversation sort
of branched out.
Like, I wasn't asking questions,
I just wanted to
know, like, which finger did
you use to stick in it?
And so we talked about it.
And he goes, well, I'm right
handed, so it's going
to be my left hand.
He says, I need my thumb and
my pinky, because you don't
want to keep hitting those.
And you need your pointer
finger to do stuff with.
And then I said, well you need
this finger, because it's the
most important thing.
And he goes yeah.
So he actually chose
his ring finger.
And as a pure engineer, it's
like, he didn't really need
his wedding band.
Even though he was married, it
didn't really matter if he cut
that finger off.
So he actually did stick his
ring finger into the table
saw, and it did work,.
And now they control
80% of the market.
And turned down by the whole
industry, but really
controlling it now.
Physical exercise.
"Research proves the
role of exercise in
keeping your brain vital.
I do all sorts of
cardio exercise.
I have advanced arthritis in one
hip, but I just went out
and ran four miles.
Obsessive personalities such
as mine help in maintaining
these pursuits.
I like to think that my
obsessions are synergistic.
When I go and run like crazy,
I come back and feel my body
and brain are all oxygenated
and ready to work."
So Bob works at Xerox.
I assume you've all used
a Xerox machine.
His optical printing is what
runs all these machines, and
it's just fascinating.
And I think all you people look
in pretty good shape.
You're riding bikes,
you're running,
you're hiking mountains.
And we all know we sort of get
that endorphin rush when we're
out there doing something.
And I know, personally, because
I do a lot of cycling,
that when I'm on my bike, I do
some of my best thinking,
which is somewhat
contradictory.
I should be doing my best
thinking when I'm sitting down
in front of a piece of paper.
But somehow, when your body
has had this relaxation
process, you get
into this zone.
And so these guys feel that
physical exercise is good.
"Never retire from inventing."
So Kevin thinks maybe when
he's dead, he's going
to retire.
So he's a research mechanical
engineer at Monsanto.
And whatever you want to think
about Monsanto, that's a whole
other discussion.
So what he's figured out is a
machine to actually read the
DNA a of a seed before
it's planted.
So it's taking a tiny little
scraping off of the seed, and
then will figure out how to
read it in a very quick
automated process.
And so I asked him, well,
how do you think?
How did you come up
with this idea?
He goes, well, my office
is in Saint Louis.
The fields are in Iowa.
It's a five or six hour drive.
I have to go out there once a
month, and I'm driving five or
six hours by myself.
And I said, I picture
myself as the seed.
I'm in the ground, and the
dirt's above me, and the sun's
above me, and the rain's
coming down.
And I say to myself, if
I was a seed, what I
would want to be.
And just the focus and
the concentration
was just really good.
And I think sometimes you have
to see the big picture.
But here he is just getting
really small, and really
looking what he was doing.
And he said to me, he's
like, I get paid.
I don't even know
what I get paid.
My check gets deposited, but
I have enough money.
And I just want to keep
doing this forever.
It was also interesting.
This guy, originally
he was in the army.
He went back to school after.
He went to community college,
took some engineering classes,
and then eventually went
back to school again.
And so some of these people just
were self trained people.
Some community college, people,
some are MIT trained,
some have advanced degrees.
So it's all facets.
Making money.
"If you make no money with your
invention, basically you
really failed in the
real world."
And this was Ron Popeil.
I'm sure you guys have seen Ron
Popeil on TV selling his
Chopomatic or his Pocket
Fisherman.
So he's still alive there, and
actually has been retired.
He sold his company a number
of years ago,.
And he has a new kitchen turkey
fryer that the whole
time while I'm interviewing,
he's trying to sell me his
turkey fryer, which was
really interesting.
And he cooks everything, so
he was just making it.
It sounded so good.
He goes to the other extreme.
So his whole validation
is on money.
And I thought that was really
interesting, because all these
other people, their validation
was on the success of their
project, the invention
and it helps society.
And he looked at as like, well,
if everyone's giving me
money, they're all using my
product, and they're getting
the advantage of that.
Though he never really looked at
the quality of what he was
doing, he just looked at the
quantity of what he was doing.
But I think it was just
fascinating listening to the
other extreme of what's
out there.
And so patents.
So I interviewed 23 people--
23 chapters, I should say.
Some were multiple people.
22 of them were inventors, and
the last two, Elizabeth and
John, were assistant
commissioners
at the patent office.
And I wanted to know,
really, about so the
question about patents.
Because IP is really important
to all of us, whether it's
hardware or software.
And these two people are now
working with individual
inventors and small
businesses.
"Throughout our history, people
have come to America
looking for their freedom and
opportunity to be independent,
create something on their
own, and claim a
piece of the universe.
This quest has driven our
success as a nation.
Our office aims to make
inventors realize that there
is assistance here for them as
they begin their innovative
journey."
I mean, what's great about this
country, and what has
made this country is
innovation, that
we have this freedom.
And the biggest freedom, I
think, is that you could fail.
You can make a zillion mistakes,
but yet, if you
achieve, you could be rewarded
for those things.
And you have that
ability there.
And so the patent office--
and everyone has a different
opinion on that, the good and
bad of patents, and I know
everyone is fighting in the
courts right now.
But patents, these guys are at
least there to help protect
the small business.
So if you guys do have
ideas, you don't
have to hire attorneys.
You could do it pro se.
They're having new programs that
they're establishing all
over the country at local
community colleges to help
people submit a patent pro se,
which just meaning submitting
to yourself.
So some of the things that I've
learned just in my career
as an inventor--
we're fascinated, we have
to do something new.
And personally, that's a lot
of pressure to put on
yourself, doing that.
So I think the way I've come to
terms with that-- the only
thing that was ever new was the
wheel, the hammer, and the
process of making fire.
And if you have those three
variables, heat,
pressure, and time--
and from those heat, pressure,
and time, you could create
anything after that.
So I never really looked that
I'm doing something new.
What I think I'm doing is trying
to modify stuff, and
try to sort of see what
was done before, and
what is the next step?
Because after I'm long and
gone, there's going to be
someone after me who's going to
look at what I did and do
the next generation of stuff.
And I also think it's
a challenge.
When you think something
is new, people
really won't get it.
I mean, there's always the first
adopters, but that's a
very small percentage.
So I think it's important to
understand and pay homage to
what someone did before, and
go to the next step.
But never think that it's going
to be so different that
it's never been done
before, because
everything has been done.
And so what does it mean
to be creative?
And to me, I think society says
that you can draw pretty
pictures, you can play an
instrument, or you can act or
whatever it may be.
But to me, creativity is all
about problem solving.
It's that simple.
That's the definition.
It's just problem solving.
And it's important, I think, as
Glen from General Electric
said, it's important to really
define what the problem is
that you're going to solve, and
then go back and make sure
there's an equal sign.
So innovation.
Big buzzword right now, as
compared to what is invention
or innovation?
So to me, innovation is the
commercialization of that idea.
It's not the idea, it's just how
you get it out there into
the marketplace, and the
marketing of it.
And the invention side is the
understanding and the
reinterpretation of scientific
or technical data.
And so, if you're inventing
something, you really have to
understand how it works,
how it's made, the
materials, and so forth.
This is just sort of
a personal thing.
To be an innovative person, to
be an inventive person, to be
a creative person, you need to
be flexible, whether that's
intellectually, emotionally,
physically.
You just need to be adaptable
all the time.
You may have sort of a solution,
and you go down that
road, and it may not work, but
you need to be able to adapt
continuously to say,
oh, I could change.
And I think that's just, as
you get older, it becomes
harder to change.
And so you have to sort
of resist all that and
continuously be flexible.
There are adrenaline junkies.
I'm an experience junkie.
And so I've jumped out of
a plane, so I don't
need to do it again.
But I just love having different
experiences.
And sometimes it's just eating
a meal or eating a food that
I've never had before.
But it's just all these
experiences add up to
opportunities and situations
that you could reference from.
And this is time I've come to
know that it doesn't matter
how smart you are or how much
money you have, this is the
only thing in the world that
is limited and you cannot
create more of.
No one will ever create more
time, so use it wisely.
I mean, it's important to look
long term down the road.
But as John Maynard Keynes
said, in the long
term, you're dead.
And that will happen
eventually.
And so use your time wisely
and really focus on what
you're doing at the moment.
If you're putting stuff out
there, I'm sure you guys think
about this all the time--
telling a good story.
You want people to buy into
what you're doing.
And so I have actually put
products out on my own, which
is a lot different than
inventing something and
handing it off to the client
or your boss or something.
And to me, being an entrepreneur
is just whatever
it is, it's taking full
responsibility for everything.
If there's a hurricane on the
east coast, it's your
responsibility if you're
trying to get
your product there.
If your employee doesn't
deliver, it's your
responsibility.
So being an entrepreneur means
taking full responsibility for
everything.
And so this is something that
a lot of beers I've come up
with this quote.
"A man climbs a mountain
because it's there.
A man invents something because
it's not there."
And this is just sort of
something in your gut.
It's like, I'm going
to do this, because
it's never been done.
I don't know why, it's just some
people like doing this.
And I have that.
And all these other
people have that.
So that's my presentation.
I hope we have some
questions now.
So the question is, how do
ethics get involved?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
To what extent is an inventor
responsible for the ethical
implications of [INAUDIBLE]?
BRETT STERN: I would say,
and I'm going to
speak for myself now--
I do what I do because my
parents gave me certain values
and ethics.
And I'm committed to making the
world a better place in a
positive way.
That's just me personally.
And the things I'm trying
to do, I think,
are helping the world.
And when I do a surgical
instrument, those things came
in front of me all day.
Like, are you extending
someone's life to be good, or
should they just die?
And these were issues
I'd faced.
It's a challenge.
I don't know.
I don't really have an answer.
I think you have to think of
them, and I think you have to
just personally say to
yourself, do I feel
comfortable putting this out
there in the marketplace?
That being said, when you give
someone a tool, whether it's
digital or analog, you have no
control over how they're
going to use it.
And to not put it out there,
to prevent it out there, I
mean, once you open up that
box, it's out there.
You have no control over it.
And good things can
be used for bad.
I don't have an answer.
I think it's just on a
case by case basis.
You have to feel comfortable
with yourself.
You can't live in
a pure world.
it's just not pure anymore.
You just have to put it out
there, do your best, and
hopefully it'll be used
for the good of man.
And that's the best
answer I can give.
So you were asking me about what
is innovation, and why is
it always commercialization
based?
I think you could invent
something and not
commercialize on it, not bring
it to the marketplace.
You can have it sit in your
garage, and that's fine.
It's your decision.
I think the reason I wanted
to give that definition is
because I think the term
inventing, invention,
creativity, innovative, they're
just terms thrown out
there all day.
And hanging out with like-minded
people, we're in
bars, and we're discussing
our projects, and it
always comes up.
And it's like, well, I'm
creative, and I'm innovative.
Well, is it the same thing?
And what are the subtleties,
differences?
And so I just made a definition
up for myself to
sort of say, when I'm doing
projects, I'm doing the
invention now.
And now I'm doing
the innovation.
And you're wearing
separate hats.
Because when you're doing the
invention side, you're wearing
the technical engineering
design hat.
But I feel when you're wearing
the innovation hat, you're
wearing the marketing and
the business side.
And it just made me feel
comfortable to understand that
they're two separate things.
Because as a designer,
everything is all about
compromise.
When you're doing art, there's
no compromise.
It's just what you're
doing for yourself.
When you do design, it's
compromising things.
And I think when you're doing
the innovation side, the
invention side is done already,
and you're trying to
get it out there.
And frankly, I want people to
give me money for the things.
I mean, you guys want people
to give you money for the
things, too, whether it's
directly or indirectly.
And you create situations where
people give you money
for your things.
And that's separate.
You don't ask the same people
who are thinking of the
technology side to figure out
ways to give you money side.
You purposely separate
those two.
And you have to wear two
different hats, because
they're two different methods.
So that's why I personally, just
me, personally-- again,
it's my definition--
is I'm able to separate that.
It's like, OK, I've done
the invention side.
Now I'm going to go out and
make some money doing it.
And frankly, I like to be
compensated for my work.
I think it's fair.
Just as everyone else
gets compensated.
So I realize that when I'm the
inventing side, I'm sort of
looking very close down.
I'm looking down at
the drawing board.
And when I'm doing the
innovation side, I am sort of
looking at the world
out there.
I'm saying, hello,
can you hear me?
So that's where I feel
comfortable.
So what tips would I share
as an inventor?
Well, I had the option of
interviewing myself, because
some of the other "At Work"
books, they did exactly that.
I thought it was surreal
to do that.
And I felt, maybe, when I did
this project, I think I was
looking for validation.
Like, I've been doing
this for 25 years.
Have I learned anything?
And so these are the masters
and everything.
So I felt I was giving
reverence to them.
And when I got to the end of
it-- so all these things?
All those skill sets?
I have all those.
So I felt pretty good
about myself.
So I feel, yes, I'm
an inventor.
I could get to wear
the inventor hat.
Whether I have patents enough or
not, I'm still an inventor.
I've made money on
my invention.
So if you get a patent,
are you an inventor?
If you make money, are
you an inventor?
I don't know.
I've done both those things.
So what have I learned?
I've learned all those
things on there.
And I learned it's
a lifestyle.
It's something that you're born
with and can be nurtured,
but it's also something you have
to live with 24/7 that
you just can't really
turn it off.
And I think some professions
that you could go in at 9:00
in the morning, hit the time
clock, and at 5:00, come home
and go out with your buddies and
watch the game, whatever.
And you could sort of
turn your brain off.
This--
and this is for all
creative people--
it's a life thing.
It's a 24/7 thing.
And so that's the best thing I
could say to a young inventor,
because I had these
conversations, is accept it.
Just, you're weird.
You think different than all the
other kids on the block.
This is how you are.
Try to be around with
like-minded people that don't
think you're so weird and crazy,
that you're thinking
all the time.
But it's OK to think this way.
And it's really quite
fun after a while.
I've made it through life so far
without ever having a job.
I've worked since I'm 14,
somehow, in the creative
industries, but I've
never had a job.
And I could say that
to other people.
Like, you could make a
living doing this.
And it's not really a living.
I mean, whatever money I make, I
blow it on the next project.
And that's really
important to me.
So I never get comfortable.
I live a very simple life.
I have a very low carbon
footprint.
I'm a single guy.
I could take everything that
I've made and just blow it on
the next thing.
The worst that can happen
is I could fail
and I'll lose money.
I'm not going to do anything
wrong or unethical or illegal.
I know that I'm not going
to be put in jail.
I pay my taxes like
everyone else.
I have health insurance.
But you can have this life
and live this way.
It's great.
And you could work in a
corporate setting, as a
consulting setting, or as an
entrepreneurial setting.
Whatever it may be.
So go forth and prosper.
It's possible.
And I think with all the turmoil
we have today, whether
in the world or in our country,
for whatever reasons,
this is such a great time to
live, because whatever worked
yesterday is not working
tomorrow.
And I mean, it's just amazing.
And it doesn't matter how old
you are or how young you are
or what education you have,
there's always a way to get
some money to do something,
whatever way it is.
I mean, whether it's from your
parents, or a credit card, or
VC, whatever, Kickstarter.
There's ways to get money to
fund these projects to just go
into the garage and
make something.
Whether it's digital, analog,
this is the most amazing time
to live right now.
With all the tools that you guys
provide out there into
the marketplace, and all the
technology and tools that
these former guys have
developed and
offered to our society.
I mean, it's just so exciting
right now with all the
materials and the technologies
and just things to try.
And it doesn't have to
be fiber optics.
It doesn't have to
be RAM memory.
It could be a new bike light,
something like that.
When the inventors created their
projects, were they also
thinking of the innovation
side?
Great question.
And I would say most of the
people I interviewed were in a
corporate or governmental
or educational setting.
And so, especially in the
corporate setting, you have
all these people out there to
do certain roles, and their
job was to do the
invention side.
They would talk with the
marketing side and the sales
side continuously, and
especially nowadays, where the
people are all brought in.
In fact, they're bringing the
manufacturing people in.
They're bringing everyone in
right from the beginning.
But I would say the actual
inventors don't really have,
in a corporate setting,
involvement in
the innovation side.
Tim Leatherman, as an example,
because he was the crazy guy
in the garage, he was out there
selling it, but he was
probably the wrong guy to
do that, because he was
too close to it.
And so most inventors are not
very good sellers of their
ideas, because they're
too wonky.
And they don't really understand
the marketing side
or the selling side of it.
So you have to be
really careful.
So I say, in a sense, to really
get stuff out there,
systems have to be in place
to separate the tasks.
So the question is, how do you
not think so much about the
invention, but the getting
it out there into the
marketplace?
AUDIENCE: Or almost
[INAUDIBLE].
BRETT STERN: You know, I think
you need to just be a well
rounded person.
And that's a challenge, because
technical people,
especially engineers,
are really focused.
I mean, their whole life has
been getting into tiny little
minutiae details.
And I think that's a challenge
for people.
I think you just have to network
and to your friends,
and go hike a mountain and
look at the world.
Go out there and just
see the world.
And I think a lot of technical
people just are marveling at
the technology, and just saying,
gee whiz, this is a
great thing that I'm doing
and in fact, never really
want to finish it.
It's like, oh, I can make it
better-- like, 2.0, 2.5, 3.
I mean, there's always going
to be something better.
And so that's what
I was saying,
like, new versus modify.
It's like, there's a point--
it's interesting, because the
computer industry will just
put stuff out there, and next
year, there's going to be the
upgraded version of that.
And even look at cars.
Every year, there's a new--
there's the 2013 coming out.
And so I think that's just
nature, is that you have to,
at some point---
this is the way I look at it.
It's like, you give birth to
your children, and you give
them certain values and morals
and education, and then you
say, OK, go off to college.
And then you could sort of have
control of them, because
you give them money
or something.
But you don't really have
that much control.
And so there's a point where
you just have to put it out
there, whether it's ready or
not, and then learn from that
experience.
Was it too soon?
Was it too late?
Did I wait too long?
Sometimes waiting too
long is a bad thing.
Sometimes it's too soon.
You put it out there,
and it gets a crappy
review, and it's sunk.
You're screwed at that point.
So there's that real
fine line.
And so you could have a
solution, and it could be
successful or failure based
on timing, based on the
marketplace, based on world
events, based on politics,
based on the physical
environment.
I don't know.
I know all this stuff,
but I know nothing.
It's like there's no
predictability in any of this.
There's no, oh, if I do this,
this will happen.
Every time it's completely
different.
And every time I think I learned
something, it's like,
I don't know.
I mean, the more I learn,
the less I know.
I mean, it's such a true
proverb right now.
But it's great to keep
learning stuff.
And you just have
to keep trying.
And I think some people become
successful when they do the
same thing over and
over again.
They sort of stay within that
industry, or that product line
or something.
I don't do that.
That's my fault.
I get screwed by learning new
stuff all the time, and
learning new experiences.
But that's my thing, and I'm
willing to accept that.
That's OK for me.
I like doing that.
And it's like the money, I'm
just going to blow it on
another idea.
It's OK.
And somehow I can make
money and just blow
it on another idea.
Right now, I'm working on
a bicycle tire project.
It's fascinating.
I've learned everything there
is about bicycle tires.
And I'm a cyclist, and I've
never done bike projects
before, and I love riding.
So where do I find knowledge,
or how do I direct it?
Well, first, you can't
rush anything.
I mean, I was in a think tank
consulting for Pfizer doing
surgical instruments
and medical
implants for seven years.
They hired me because I
knew nothing about it.
They wanted that out of
the box thinking.
They brought a doctor in to,
like, OK, this is how we do
angioplasty surgery.
And the next project
would be, this is
how we do hip implants.
And it's like, OK.
But my job, in those situations,
at least, is to
say what if?
Now, it wasn't my job
to be a doctor.
It wasn't my job to be a
mechanical engineer or a
biomechanical engineer.
It was my job to say, why are
you doing it that way?
We went to Japan to
do orthopedics
for the Asian market.
The first night we there, we
were sitting on the floor in
the restaurant drinking beers.
And I said, do you guys design
these implants for people to
sit on the floors?
And we were all the Americans
in Japan.
It's like, who sits on
floors in America?
And that was it.
It was like, my job was done.
Drinking a beer, I said,
do you sit on a floor?
It's like, no.
Let's design implants for people
to have increased range
of motion, is really what
it was all about.
And then looking at the
physiology of the body.
I didn't have to come
up with a solution.
I'm so far in the front of it.
There are all these
people behind.
And I think you need all those
experts to be in the room.
I mean, are you personally
responsible for putting
something out there into
the marketplace right
now, here at Google?
You're not.
You have all these teams of
people that you work on.
And I think the problem
inventors have is when they
think they know everything, or
they want to learn everything.
And what happens is they do get
bogged down, and they're
like, oh, I have to go back to
school to become a physicist.
I have to go get my engineering
degree.
It's like, no, you could just
hire an engineer to do that.
I mean, I hire people
all the time.
I'm an industrial designer.
I don't do any mechanical
drawing anymore.
There's young people out there
that I could hire to do this
in 15 minutes or an hour.
I don't have to learn all these
CAD drawings anymore.
I could say, I want this.
I give a sketch, and it's like,
the back of a napkin.
It works fine.
So you find experts.
And that's how you become
the expert.
But it's important for you
to continuously ask
them to those questions.
Like, why are you doing that?
What are the three variables?
And if they give you something
back and say, OK, here's the
solutions, it's like, why?
Could we do it some other way?
And that's what the out of
the box thinking is.
It's like, why are
you doing this?
And asking this question.
So ask questions continuously.
And there's nothing wrong
with the question.
People may get pissed at
you, because they may
not know the answer.
That's when people get annoyed--
when they don't know
the answers, and they're
supposed to be the experts.
And then you just find
a different expert.
So just keep asking questions.
MALE SPEAKER: On that note,
those are some great
questions, and a great
presentation.
BRETT STERN: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks a lot,
Brett, for speaking with us.
[APPLAUSE]